georges fillioud imaginons maintenant
que les socialistes reviennent au
pouvoir en 88
c'est quoi alors parce que les mesures
par de l'image ou de chien 1 c'est pas
d'imagination en section forte
rentabilité
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer sur
l'a5
moi je me garderai bien de faire
dépenser chez un patient pour expliquer
tout ce qui allait se passer là non vous
serez pas étonné qu'avec un journaliste
et professionnels de l'audiovisuel et
n'ayant cessé de m'occuper de ces
questions en tant que député ayant été
cinq ans ministre comme une question ait
autant que je continue de suivre ces
problèmes je m'y intéresse
l'assise devenir une chaîne musicale les
décisions seront prises le moment venu
simplement ce que je veux dire c'est que
personnellement je souhaite c'est parce
qu'il sera le moment venu décider ce que
je souhaite c'est que l'on n'assiste pas
à un nouveau chambardement complet de
l'ensemble de nationaliser par exemple
on a peut-être qu il appartiendra à ceux
qui auront à les prendre prendre des
décisions comment vivez vous votre
rapport quand même vous prévoyez bien de
deux mariés antenne 2 et fr3 et tout ça
quand même
je crois en effet raisonnable wedge sous
une forme ou sous une autre
art
donnez raisonnable et nécessaire de
donner une structure unique qu'est ce
qui vit à la maison et on parle bien
quand même par d'autres choses avancent
et la haute autorité ça va revenir
je ne sais pas s'il existe encore
beaucoup d'un défenseur sincère de la
sienne aujourd'hui je suis réponse le 12
mars 86 j'ai été nommé conseiller d'état
ça consiste en quoi les français d etat
comme travail conseil d'état a deux
fonctions
il est d'une part le conseil juridique
du gouvernement mais de l'ensemble des
pouvoirs publics il le consulte
obligatoirement sur les projets de noir
sur les décrets important et il est
d'autre part
l'instance de juridiction administrative
d'appel le plus élevé c'est-à-dire de
l'ensemble des juridictions administré
des coups bureau consacrant pas
burnhaupt que des bibliothèques des
grandes salles avant alors ils
transportaient depuis combien pas
beaucoup ah bon vous l'aurez
thessalonique avec beaucoup il a des
délits fratrie ce qui s'appelle des
codes et toutes ses phrases commencent
par attendu que attendu que c'est bien
payé son exercice nombre d'accidents dit
aux journalistes d'exercice de rédaction
que voiture mais quand on est facile et
assez pour longtemps c'est en principe
jusqu'à ce qu'on décide d'en partir
ou un manche où est ce que je sais mais
c'est exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel on
est là pour un moment alors la fin on
peut dû repartir pour être chose vous
publier un roman chez françois bourin
s'appelle la mort d'un chien s'équipent
françois bourrin et bien sûr un jeune
éditeur indépendant qui est de
le fils de jeanne bourin oui on en tire
du moyen-âge jambes des dames ctk va
créer cette maison d'édition il ya
quelques mois et j'ai la chance d'être
l'un des premiers auteurs en fin de 5e
ou 6e auteur publié par cette histoire
c'est l'histoire d'un comptable qui
virait était plein de ressentiment
justement alors c'est un gars de vous
finalement oui ça me fait penser à ce
que man mes amis ayant lu le livre on me
disait c'est un contre fille new way bon
mais cela dit c'est pas parce que
l'histoire commence savez exorciser
notre ressentiment leur faisant non nous
apporter sur un an
carrément gêné j'ai essayé d'inventer
une histoire qui concerne premier roman
chez mon premier roman depuis bien
longtemps
ne parlons pas de ceux qui sont enterrés
depuis des lustres norme est ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est en effet
daniel a raison c'est un roman l'air ça
peut surprendre un peu de la part
de quelqu'un gavron sacré beaucoup
beaucoup de temps de sa vie à la
politique mais ya rien de politique
c'est l'histoire d'un homme ordinaire
s'est pas non plus autobiographique pas
non plus régeard étant alors ces
derniers mois un vrai don à la maison au
sein des avions en plus de son boulot de
façon johnny est enfermé dans un bureau
toute la journée devant la cour il
écrivait elle alors en parlant de la
cour justement c'est bientôt votre
anniversaire
oui gâteau c'est quand 23 avril quelque
chose à saint georges
en plus on avait comme une sourde à
saint georges mais emi avec l'onu
comment dans un festival de télévision
qui s'érige comme ouais je sais tout
simplement
on nous a présenté depuis cinq ans ça
n'a pas varié d'un depuis cinq ans
l'économie nice les causes que nicosie
l'état maintenant je connais comme
romancier alors qu'il préférait lequel
je les aime tous mais j'aime bien le
romancier et le poser l'état parce qu'il
est comme beaucoup à la maison vous
sortez dans les bras sous les neiges
déjà venu ici restent elles sont très
amis et castel à leurs avants c'est une
maison
dans radikal on peut le dire sans faire
concurrence pas du tout pas du tout fait
que par les gens débarquer ici mes
cascades monde voyait du monde est si
gentille souvient le vendredi williams a
obtenu hier vendredi c'est terrible
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une autre série
marie pervenche est encore une jeune fan
comme l'aromate mal en ce moment
écoutez là ce n'est pas paul andreu de
ça c'est christian baril envie de
m'essayer de notre série s'écrit ce
matin qu écrit dix fois et une heure et
demie
et puis il ya encore d'autres marie
pervenche berès peur chez vous chez
georges kiejman
écoutez le projet il m'a dit après
l'abordage chien je sais qu'il a
d'autres idées en tête il a envie
d'écrire c'est un romancier les
giallorossi ont suivi le fait perdu pour
l'audiovisuel je vais vous dire une
chose il doit il a écrit entre temps ans
3,86 et celui ci amanda chien il a vexé
un autre roman qu'il n'y a pas plus
vraiment là mieux à tiroirs donc il en
plus il a l'oeil il écrit une écrit il à
abandonner définitivement
donc j'ai une vie des tunisiens alors il
ya un truc moi qui me plaisait bien
coexister libertinage sur la dame s'est
dite est renvoyé mais pourquoi vous
souhaitez envoyer votre homme politique
- la vérifier
la vérité c'est que
les gens de rmc qui sont arrivés les
nouveaux jeux c'est pas changer le
programme
ils ont ouvert ils sont des élèves des
dames i feel you dos rond il y avait
chez moi un truc avant de le rencontrer
c'est comme marie démange à des signes
tandis qu'à l'avant pognon rmc j'ai
également engagés du temps que j'attends
ma femme de dire qu'il faut savoir avant
rien mais très loin des honneurs s'est
pas vu nadal temps des corrections de ne
rien rater de winne a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux